let's say that there's a country that's
made up only of this island and that's
sitting in the middle of the lake and on
that island there's only one dude here
he has one house and he has some land on
which crops can be grown but he wants to
think a little bit more formally about
his economy and he starts setting up
some institutions that start to resemble
things that we would see in more complex
economies so what he decides to do is he
decides to set up a firm so let me put
the firm right over here he decides to
create a legal entity call some firm
over here some corporation and he's
sitting here he's the household he's a
household of exactly one person so this
is him as a household and he decides to
give multiple factors of production to
the firm so he gives factors of
production to the firm so he gives he
essentially rents out his building so he
gives capital he rents out the land to
the firm so he gets he's giving a land
and he also works for the firm so he is
giving labour and he is the owner of the
firm and he's he was the guy who thought
of this entrepreneurial activity so he's
also giving the factor of production
that sometimes thrown in there is
entrepreneurship entrepreneurship I'll
just I'll just abbreviate it just like
that and in return the firm will
essentially pay rents for these factors
of production so the firm will pay him
will pay him money in exchange for being
allowed to use all of these things so
for the rent on the capital on the
building itself so for the building the
building and we'll talk about let's say
this is all in a given year for the
building he the firm is going to pay him
the firm that he owns is going to pay
him $1,000 per year $1,000 so this is
the building rent let me make it clear
that this is building rent or building
lease building rent it's going to pay
him $1,000 for the land for the land
rent he's also going to get paid another
thousand dollars and then for his wages
essentially the rent on his labor so his
wages you could view that as
and on labor they're renting his is
energy in his time his wages he's also
going to get $1,000 per year did I say
$1,000 per month it should be $1,000 per
year so he's getting $1,000 a month in
building rent thousand dollars a month
in land and $1,000 a month in wages and
he gets whatever profit whatever profit
comes from the firm because he is the
owner of the of the firm and you could
say that that's the compensation in
exchange for his entrepreneurship so in
this and looking at only this part or
these two lines the household he is
providing all of the factors of
production for the firm so that the firm
can produce useful things so the firm
can produce goods and services and it's
good that the firm will produce goods
and services because this household
needs to survive he needs a place to
stay and he needs food to eat and so
let's say with the labor and this land
and you know so this guy is working at
this farm and it has this land and all
of the rest its able to produce some
food and so it sells it sells him goods
and services so it sells it sells this
household goods and services and in
particular it sells him food and it also
rents out the property and I think you
could see this is already getting kind
of circular here he's essentially
renting out his own property but this is
a nice simple example obviously once you
expand beyond what more than one person
or more than one firm things get
complicated fast so he's getting food
and shelter and in exchange for the food
in the shelter he's going to pay the
firm in exchange for that he's going to
pay the firm and so he's going to pay
the firm let's just say that he decides
there's it much of a market right over
here he is the market but let's say for
the food for the food he decides to pay
he's pays $2,300 $2,300 a year for the
food and for the use of the of the
building that is that the firm is
renting he is paying let's say he's
paying $1,200 rent of $1,200 so a couple
of ways to think about it you can look
at it from the households point of view
what are his total expenditures well
total expenditures come out - what 3,500
hours so this is total let me do this in
a different color this is total total
expenditures for this household and
what's his total income well he gets
$1,000 for the building thousand dollars
for land thousand dollars for wages and
he gets some profit from that firm so we
don't know what that profit is so look
why don't we hold off a little bit on
his total income so I'll just write it
here total total income we don't quite
know what that is yet because we have to
figure out how much profit he's getting
from the firm so let's look at the
firm's point of view what is the total
revenue that they are getting for the
firm the total revenue total revenue
well he's getting 20 the firm is getting
twenty three hundred dollars for the
food $1,200 for the rent getting total
revenue of $3,500 per year everything
years on an annual basis I'm a feeling I
said per month by accident a few times
everything here is on an annual basis
getting $3,500 per year and what are the
firm's expenditures well the firm has to
has so this is expenses and here we're
going to be thinking in terms of
economic profit because we're really
just thinking about how much money is
coming out of this firm out of this
business
so expenses so for the building the
building the firm has to pay one
thousand dollars for the land the firm
has to pay one thousand dollars and for
the labor and for the labor the firm
also has to pay one thousand dollars and
so what's left over is the profit we're
assuming that there's no taxes over here
this is the profit for the owners $3,500
- three thousand gives us a profit of
five hundred dollars and that's going to
go to the owner of the firm who happens
to be this guy right over here so the
profit is five hundred dollars and so
his total income is $3,500 $3,500 and
it's good that his income is at least
$3,500 because that's how much he's
spending it per month spending per month
now the whole reason why I did this is
to kind of show you the circular flow of
goods and services these are the goods
and services up here let me show these
are the goods and services goods
and services the firm's provide the
households goods and services and then
the households are providing the firm's
the factors of production and sometimes
you might say well aren't other firms
also providing the factors of production
yes other firms could if there were
other firms but those firms and the end
of the day are owned by someone they are
getting their factors of production by
some household or they are owned by some
household so you can view it as that at
the end of the day the households are
really giving the firm's the factors of
production factors factors of production
and in exchange for the factors of
production the households in exchange
for giving these things the firm's give
the households income essentially rents
on the different factors of production
that are being given to the firm for the
most part and over here in exchange for
the goods and services the households
are making expenditures that can also be
considered revenue of the firm now if
you are an economist that were to
observe this and I guess if we were
focused on this island maybe he would
also have to be the island economist and
you would say how would you measure how
would you measure the total the total
value of the product the production of
my country here maybe we could call it
the gross domestic product how would we
measure it would you count just the
total expenditures or would you count
the total expenditures and the total
income or would you even count that and
the revenue well if you can at all of
that you would be essentially triple
counting if you counted the total
revenue the total expenditures and the
total income they're all that $3500 you
would be triple counting so what you
could do you could just measure only one
of these things you could say your GDP
your gross domestic product your gross
domestic product is the total
expenditures by the households so it
would be the $3,500 you could say it is
the total income by the households so
that would also be $3,500 and the total
revenue really is the same thing as the
total expenditures so the whole point of
this video and this is obviously a very
artificial case where we're dealing with
an island with only one person and he's
essentially renting out his own labor
but by using this firm is some type of a
vehicle he's he's consuming his own
labour he is renting out a house from a
firm that he has rented his house to so
is very very very circular but hopefully
this appreciate you kind of appreciate
how the resources are going around in
this kind of a circular flow